-Noah and I are about
to face off in a water war.
We'll play the card game "War."
But if you lose the hand, you
get a pint of water in the face.
The first person
to throw five glasses wins
and gets to water-cannon
the loser.
[ Laughter, cheering ]
Noah, are you ready to do this?
-Oh, born ready!
-Here we go. Now, you trust
that it's not rigged, right?
-What?
-You trust?
-I don't know, man.
Should I trust you?
-Yeah, of course.
-Alright, then I trust you.
-I can -- You want me to cut the
deck?
I can do whatever you want.
Alright. Ready?
-I'm ready. 3, 2, 3.
-1, 2, 3.
Or maybe it is rigged.
Alright, maybe we should --
-So that's --
-Yeah, that's --
I get water to the face.
This game --
-Jimmy, I want to you think
of a time in your life
when you were in bed.
And you felt
a cool, cool liquid...
that wasn't cool at all.
It was actually warm!
[ Cheers and applause ]
You peed yourself!
Oh, that's so embarrassing!
-I didn't see that coming.
I did not see that coming
at all. Let's go.
Now it's war, dude.
Let's do this. Here we go.
-Alright.
-3, 2, 1!
-Yes!
-Aah!
I want to you
to think about a time...
[ Laughter ]
...in your bed.
-Okay. [ Laughs ]
You're having a dream that
you're going down a water slide!
-[ Screams ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Refreshing, isn't it?
-I like it!
[ Laughter ]
I want more!
-Alright, let's do it!
-Alright.
-1, 2, 3!
-Yes!
-No.
-Dude, thank you so much
for coming on the show.
You are the best, dude.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ] Whoo!
I love this game.
-I appreciate it.
-Except I'm sitting
in cold water right now,
so you really did win already.
-This is -- I'm like --
It's like Wim Hof.
-Yeah, here we go.
-Alright.
-3, 2, 1!
-Yes!
-Come on! How is this?
-This is unbelievable.
Dude, this is crazy.
I love this, man.
This is awesome. Alright.
-Be gentle.
-Yeah, I will.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-It feels good, right?
It feels really good, yeah.
-Oh, my God.
-This is the best game
I've ever played.
-Okay, okay, okay. 3, 2 --
-You looking at it first?
How do you feel like
your odds are?
3, 2, 1.
Oh!
-Ooh.
That's a war.
Alright. So we have to --
-So now --
-It's three cards, right?
And then --
-No, but then with a war,
you put your glass in a pitcher,
and then someone gets
the pitcher in the head.
Alright, here we go.
So we do --
-We got to put that --
-Yeah, you don't even
have room for -- Yeah.
So we do one card.
-1, 2, 3.
-2, 3.
-Flip.
-Oh, come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Jimmy! What happened, man?
What happened?!
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And a cup --
They're saying and one cup, too.
-And a cup.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers ]
-[ Coughs ]
[ Gasping ]
That is freezing.
That water's ice cold.
Oh, my gosh.
That is freezing water.
-They got this
from the cold pipe.
-What you need is warm --
Alright. Here we go.
-Alright.
-1, 2, 3.
-2, 3.
-Oh, come on.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Just --
-Alright.
-I need you to just --
Yep, yep.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Whoo!
Iceman.
-Alright, okay.
-Wim Hof. Come on.
-Alright. Alright. Here we go.
-Alright, alright.
-Three, two, one.
-Oh, come on now!
This is insane!
I want to switch --
I want to switch decks.
This is --
This is rigged.
I drank a little bit
of that last one.
I drank a little bit of
the last one. Okay.
-Listen, we got start --
-This feels rigged.
Oh, my gosh.
Alright. Here we go.
-Now, it's --
Now it's really cold.
-Now I'm awake. Now I'm awake.
Here we go.
-Okay.
-Here we go, yeah.
-2, 1.
-Alright. Come on.
This is -- Alright.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
How did you come back?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh. I hate this game.
Alright. Here we go. Last one.
Oh, my gosh. Oh, my gosh.
-This is -- I feel --
-I have to host
the rest of the show like this.
-I feel bad, man!
-Here we go. Alright.
-3, 2, 1.
-1, 2, 3. Go.
-Oh, my gosh! You won!
You won. You get to --
[ Dinging ]
Oh, my God.
-There you go, buddy. Go for it.
-How do we do this?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yep. Go for it.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Let's go!
-Noah Centineo,
the winner, everybody!
More with Noah after the break!
Come on back
for more "Tonight Show"!
Oh, my gosh.
-Oh, geez.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We'll be right back.
You are dead meat.